former minneapolis police officer derek
shovin is scheduled to be sentenced on
june 16th
shovin is being held in solitary
confinement at a maximum security prison
after a jury convicted him of murder and
manslaughter for the death of george
floyd
the maximum sentence could be 40 years
in prison but legal experts say 30 years
is more likely the verdict last week
brought calm to the twin cities and a
renewed push for police reform
even among some police officers jamie
yukis
spoke to one as the country held its
breath for the verdict
the twin cities braced for potential
unrest and then
guilty saint paul police officer antoine
denson was relieved
justice for the moment was served we
have a long way to go
we have a lot of police reform
a lot of cultural reform that we have to
work on
as a police entity but again
we shouldn't be in this point in the
first place you're a police officer
saying there needs to be police reform
absolutely there needs to be police
reform what does that look like
that's the million dollar question when
you watch the trial and you saw
one after the other police officer get
up on the stand
do you think this is part of breaking
that blue wall of silence
absolutely um i dislike the blue line i
understand the concept of it but
i mean we we're creating division and it
can't be a division amongst police
officers versus the people
we are a part of the community last year
shortly after george floyd's death
denson was spotted taking a knee and
crying at a protest
i'm not afraid to say that we have a
problem within
our law enforcement and in our judicial
system and we've been crying this same
fight for over and over
and over again
[Applause]
black lives matter is just not a
movement and i think
a lot of white people think of it as a
threat and it's not a threat it's
an outcry for help denson walks a fine
line between being critical of the job
and understanding its challenges
officers
are playing modern warfare on the
streets it is a career of authority
but just we're using it to look down
upon people well let's stop looking down
upon people and let's help elevate
people
so from a law enforcement standpoint
when you see all of these police
interactions getting lumped together
what does it
say to you of course no one wants to see
an individual lose their lives the issue
is we're putting it all together and
it's causing such a reaction
from the black community because it's so
much pain and i
get it it's so much pain but to help
us heal let's look at every single
incident as its entity and uh
just deal with in that manner does it
not speak to you that there's a larger
issue
of policing with black communities
there's so many layers
and it's hard to i guess to
to feel sympathy with the history of law
enforcement
i mean officers are our people as well
tearing down the blue wall of silence
to build a bridge of healing for cbs
this morning saturday jamie yukas
minneapolis
i think the officers i've spoken to
believe that once you feel
like you're part of a community you're
better able to police it and if you have
that distance
it's a tough job the one thing i think
we've seen since the verdict is that
reminder of
the work is just starting this was not
the end this was just the beginning and
a reminder too that the
trial for the three other officers
involved hasn't taken place yet that
starts in
late august